[Musique]
et pour terminer cette semaine spéciale
agriculture nous allons plaisir
d'accueillir un grand chef étoilé
bonjour thierry marx bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous dans accepté
notre invitation
vous êtes l'auteur de ce livre également
celui qui ne combat pas déjà perdu 7 aux
éditions flammarion et on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes prenez interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par pascal jalabert
du groupe ebra bonjour pascal le groupe
ebra les journaux régionaux de l'est de
la france
thierry marx vous êtes un habitué du
salon de l'agriculture qui n'a pas lieu
cette année pour cause de crise
sanitaire bien évidemment est ce que
c'est un grand vide pour vous et est-ce
que c'est aussi un coup dur pour la
profession d'agriculteur qui se voient
privés d'un coup de projecteur peut-être
le plus important de l'année
non c'est un véritable coup dur d'avoir
ça permet au monde agricole et peut-être
au monde urbain de de se rencontrer de
se comprendre de mieux travailler
ensemble et de mieux vivre ensemble
et puis de comprendre les enjeux de
cette agriculture c'est un jeu
planétaire est l'enjeu de l'alimentation
parce qu'on a beaucoup parlé de cette de
ce virus finalement mais très très peu
de l'alimentation et les agriculteurs
sur les premiers mobilisés sur notre
alimentation de demain alors justement
on a vu pas inscrits sanitaire que les
français ont retrouvé le goût pour
manger local pour ce qu'on appelle les
circuits qu'on vous y croyez et comment
on peut mettre ça en place
alors j'y crois bien évidemment le
mettre en place ce n'est pas aussi
simple
ça a l'air comme ça
dans les éléments de langage sur la
rhétorique de plateau on peut le faire
mais
je vous donne un exemple dans nos
entreprises on a choisi d'être hq haute
qualité environnementale d'être capable
de mesurer notre impact social et notre
impact environnemental
et bien quand on a mis en place nos
circuits courts notre relocalisation
bias a pas été aussi simple autant la
grande distribution c'est le faire parce
que ça fait trente ans qu'elle sait
mesurer cet impact là mais nous c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué donc j'y crois
c'est absolument nécessaire pour avoir
une bonne alimentation de redonner cet
élan du circuit court cette
relocalisation et puis d'aider les
agriculteurs à faire cette transition
dont il a besoin
quand vous quand vous dites compliqué qu
est-ce qui a été compliqué pour mettre
en logistique la logistique ou non
personnellement on a investi beaucoup
dans des grecs
on a rencontré des grecs on a mis un
petit peu d'argent dans ces galets
groupe roumain dans des groupes ont un
gros point de vue cole pardon et
aujourd'hui c'est une véritable réussite
la qualité des produits et la le circuit
vivre ça nous sommes en capacité de
payer un peu plus l'agriculteur mais
c'est pas aussi simple que ça en a l'air
il a fallu justement pensez vous que les
français soient en capacité 1 envie de
payer un peu plus pour mieux manger
manger plus local et pour manger
meilleur km
mais bien sûr que les français ils ont
envie de mieux manger un peu plus le
prix n'est pas la valeur s'est dit
warren buffet tu mets film et le prix
n'est pas la valeur ce qu'il faut aider
faire en sorte c'est la pac sociale
comment j'aide des personnes à monter en
compétences avoir un statut social un
peu plus élevé pour qu'ils puissent
consommer mieux pour que leur
alimentation soit soit meilleur mais
bien sûr que aujourd'hui payer un petit
peu plus ça doit avoir du sens et une
baguette de pain g prendre juste
l'exemple de la baguette de pain une
baguette de pain à 80 centimes d'euro ça
ne peut y avoir aucun sens ça ne protège
pas une filière ricol ça ne protège pas
une pierre de l'artisanat et ça ne vous
protège pas un temps de consommateurs
une baguette à 1 euro 20 louis donc et
donc les publics à pouvoir s'alimenter
de façon meilleur et ensuite eh bien on
pourra aider cette agriculture à faire
cette transition dont elle a besoin et
vous le savez thierry marx ni aux
personnes les agriculteurs aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'entre eux n'arrivent pas à
vivre du fruit de leur travail à des
négociations qui sont actuellement en
cours entre les producteurs et les
distributeurs
est ce que vous trouvez que les grandes
surfaces elles jouent suffisamment le
jeu je pense que les
les grandes surfaces et notamment
certains qui sont vraiment très impliqué
là dedans au fait un effort il faut
encore bien sûr aller plus loin à mon
avis mais je pense que tout le monde
aujourd'hui cherchent des solutions
je pense qu'on est passé un stade où il
faut arrêter de chercher des coupables
et chercher des solutions pour que tout
le monde
il trouve vraiment vraiment son compte
mais bien sûr que aujourd'hui la grande
distribution étaient tellement un flux
important de clients que vous finissez
par céder à l'appel du petit prix et ce
qui a tué voire très abîmée pas tué
heureusement notre agriculture comme
notre industrie d'ailleurs c'est cette
théorie du low cost du tout pas cher
finalement ça nous met dans des
situations de compétition qui sont
insupportables pour les industriels mais
aussi pour pour les agriculteurs donc
cette théorie du low cost
il faut lui tordre le cou définitivement
et on a une date historique avec cette
covit pour dire notre alimentation de
demain c'est pas la théorie du low cost
et vous pensez que l'état d'esprit des
français peut changer on a vu un retour
au circuit court au mois de mars au mois
d'avril lors du premier confinement mais
c'est vrai que cet été les français ils
ont un peu repris leurs habitudes et se
sont retournés vers la grande
distribution vers les grandes surfaces
est ce que vous pensez que ça peut être
durable ce changement de mentalité
mais je pense que ça va être durable
parce que je vais prendre une vieille
phrase mais memento mori
on vient de se rendre compte que notre
alimentation pouvait nous tuer et on a
beaucoup parlé de la kz1 on a beaucoup
parlé de masque on a beaucoup parlé de
règles sanitaires
on a très peu parlé d'alimentation
d'ailleurs il faut lire les écrits de
pierre bayle ce qu'il a fait pour
l'inserm à rennes c'est passionnant on a
très peu parlé d'alimentation or que la
corée le japon a dès le 1er confinement
travailler sur les conséquences de notre
alimentation sur cet impact
l'impact de ce virus donc il faut
travailler son agrément sur une
alimentation de qualité passe par une
agriculture de qualité ça les
agriculteurs l'ont compris mais il faut
les aider dans cette transition c'est
pas en leur parlant de bio toutes les
cinq minutes que ça fait avancer que ça
fait avancer les choses il faut aider à
cette relocalisation aider à cette
transition en bio parce qu'on s'aperçoit
que la chimie finalement nous fait plus
faire de progrès à l'hectare donc la
chimie n'est plus la solution
qu'il faut revenir à des choses à des
sols de qualité pour avoir des plantes
de qualité pour avoir des élevages de
qualité et que la filière alimentaire
soit une infime filière scène donc
aujourd'hui tout ça il faut le mettre en
mouvement il faut encore une fois je
vous dis arrêtez avec les mondes langage
et le mettre en place c'est à dire que
les pouvoirs publics qui ne sont pas
toujours au rendez-vous à dire que les
pouvoirs publics
j'ai souvent l'impression qu'ils qu'ils
comptent un peu les points je pense
qu'aujourd'hui encore une fois je vais
reprendre ce propos mais d'avoir des
rhétoriques de plateaux d'être les mieux
disant bien il faut arrêter d'être les
mieux disant et dire voilà on va faire
on va pas gagner tout de suite un
business model dans l'aviculture faut
oublier que c'est entre 10 et 15 ans
c'est pas une start up en ont fait une
application on décide pendant dix ans de
changer de la qualité seul de travailler
sur la qualité des sols pour voir une
qualité des plantes etc pour améliorer
les élèves alsa et puis de reconnaître
que dans notre alimentation on a intérêt
aussi à savoir reproduire de la protéine
végétale en france est de continuer à
faire ses besoins qu'un la france en
termes d'alimentation
oui tu as lité parce que oui alors juste
une question cette crise a été marquée
par le boom un peu des services à
domicile qu'on prive de restauration
vous craignez que les gens délaissent le
restaurant ou que les restaurateurs sont
obligées de s'adapter à ça c'est à dire
avoir une partie physique et une part
qui je livre à domicile alors ski ski
bac comme tous les phénomènes de crise
on va apprendre
donc je pense que les il n'y aura pas de
désintérêt pour le restaurant fait le
lien social du commerce le lien social
delà du restaurant c'est pas simplement
le contenu de l'assiette c'est tout tout
ce qui tout ce qui est globale donc il y
aura pas d intérêt mais par contre on
voit des facteurs qui sont importants
des signaux faibles de cette vente à
emporter qui aujourd'hui nous permet de
d'aller chercher des comptages de
chiffre d'affaires donc ça ça restera
dans dans la façon d'aller au restaurant
d'y aller ou de se faire livrer et ça je
crois que ça va être un comptage de
chiffre d'affaires pour les pour ces
métiers
vous êtes une chance sur le fait que les
français rejoindre aurait totalement
j'ai regardé j'ai regardé les dernières
études qui ont été faites et on
s'aperçoit que les français sont en on
attend de leur restaurant parce que
c'est du lien social y compris le café
du matin avec le journal papier que vous
avez sur le contenu même si ce dernier
joue même si le café pas exceptionnel
vous dites j'ai rencontré du monde et
c'est ça qui est formidable
il ya quelques sujets d'actualité sur
lesquels on aimerait vous entendre
thierry marx et notamment cette décision
du maire de lyon maire écologiste de
lyon grégory douce et d'instaurer des
menus uniques sans viande dans les
cantines de sa ville pour raison
sanitaire qu'est ce que vous avez pensé
de cette décision je ne pense pas qu'il
faille
je suis végétarien donc je peux parler
aisément tu là je pense pas qu'il faille
ostracisé l'avion quand tu vois ce type
de décision je trouve que c'est c'est
assez radical je trouve pas ça vraiment
très intéressant je pense qu'il faut
mais je vais faire une une boutade un
peu idiote mais je pense que le xxème
siècle c'était le boeuf carottes
je crois qu'il faut passer aux carottes
boeuf je crois qu'il faut donner du la
flexibilité à notre alimentation
diminuer la protéine animale parce que
ça environnementalement ça aura un
impact mais ne pas ostraciser tous les
éleveurs donc je pense 80 c'est bien 80
% végétal 20% protéines animales est une
sage décision
l'autre actualité qui date d'hier soir
c'est la mairie de paris qui va proposer
un confinement de trois semaines c'est
ce qu'elle va proposer à jean castex est
derrière elle veut pouvoir ouvrir les
théâtres mais aussi les bars et les
restaurants est ce que vous soutenez
cette solution ou est ce que vous dites
trois semaines c'est pas faisable c'est
pas réaliste
j'ai pu très honnêtement pas de
vous obligera à rouvrir dans trois
semaines oui oui oui je prie même dès
demain pour avec mes confrères ont pris
pour et ouvriront une réouverture en
avril progressive des terrasses je
trouve que ce serait très très bien et
on sait très bien que la grande
ouverture pourrait être juillet mais d
une ouverture progressive en avril vous
savez ça nous ça nous donnerait de
l'oxygène parce que aujourd'hui ce que
nous vivons dans notre profession c'est
sympa on crée de la dette et on n'a pas
l'habitude on est des artisans
donc on voit bien que notre trésorerie
elle était épuisée que nous continuons à
payer des taxes et que nous endettons
donc il faut il faut ré ouvrir et qu'une
entreprise reste une entreprise une
entreprise c'est pas un grille pain
qu'on branche et qu'on débranche comment
vous tenez par du chômage partiel par
les livraisons à domicile comment vous
faites tout est bon à prendre cher que
il ya effectivement repenser le
dispositif d'entreprises ont que les
personnes qui pouvaient son département
en l'occurrence la boulangerie la
pâtisserie et puis le métier du snacking
la vente à emporter
bien sûr un peu de chômage partiel et on
a essayé de trouver les ingrédients
qu'il fallait pour équilibrer un petit
peu tout ça et puis l'hôtel est resté
ouvert et l'hôtel permet ces services en
chambre dans de bonnes conditions
sanitaires donc voilà tout ça sont des
des actions économiques qui maintiennent
la lumière allumée mais qui sont bien
loin de 2 de faire le revenu nécessaire
pour avoir une capacité à reprendre une
activité pleine et entière
vous avez un regard qui va au delà de la
france vous avez plusieurs
établissements vous pouvez donc comparé
notamment au niveau des z est ce que
vous dites qu'en france vous avez été
quand même plus et dès qu'il faut aux
établissements forcé français s'en
sortent mieux que vous établissements
hors de france alors en france on a été
vraiment aidé c'est vrai alors le pge
j'ai pas confié que c'était une aide
parce que c'est un emprunt et il va
falloir le rembourser mais je pense
qu'il ya eu un phénomène d'amortisseur
avec les aides françaises que j'ai pas
eue sur le japon je n'ai pas eu
sur d'autres pays dans lequel j'ai
travaillé mais on a été aussi moins
fermés dans d'autres pays voir le japon
quasiment pas l'accord est quasiment pas
et les états unis quasiment pas donc ça
nous a permis d'équilibrer un petit peu
de chose mais en france il ya eu quand
même ce phénomène rassurant et notamment
du chômage partiel parce que pour les
collaborateurs c'était une anxiété
absolue a été condamné à indemniser un
restaurateur
je trouve que les assureurs ont joué le
jeu encore une fois je veux pas
ostraciser une profession par rapport à
une autre mais les assureurs quand ils
ont un contrat il doit le respecter donc
je pense que axa ou d'autres doivent
s'appliquer à appliquer la règle et
quand vous avez souscrit pendant des
années à une assurance vous vous
attendez que en cas de pépin en cas de
problème et bien l'assurance soit à vos
côtés donc je pense que voilà oui
les assureurs les banques tout le monde
doit se serrer les coudes
aujourd'hui pour aider l'économie parce
que si l'économie s'effondre et savez
nous on est des pme mais si on
s'effondre on ne verra même pas mais ya
de plus grosses structures aujourd'hui
qui sont en grande difficulté
et là ça pourrait créer des trous d'air
économique qui serait d'aider tous des
trous assez empirique toile justement
qu'est-ce que vous parlez trop d'air
économique est ce que vous êtes inquiète
sur la prêt pour le moment les aides de
l'état sont là le gouvernement le dit il
sera aux côtés des secteurs en
difficulté comme la restauration tant
que la crise sanitaire sera là mais
après il faudra que le quoi qu'il en
coûte s'arrête c'est ce qu'a dit le
gouvernement est ce que vous êtes
inquiet sur 7 après alors je trouve que
pessimiste ou optimiste et des postures
donc je pense qu'on attend on avance
tous présents et on voit des signaux
faibles économique qui repartent qui
vont être intéressants vous avez parlé
du de la vente à emporter on voit que
cette mise en ligne de notre profession
aujourd'hui c'est de vente en ligne vin
va générer du revenu
il ya un ensemble de choses qui vont
disparaître aussi ça c'est assez
catastrophique et des confrères qui
étaient déjà en grande difficulté qui
risque de disparaître
mais je pense qu'ils j'ai bon espoir
de ceux de cette relance parce que il va
y avoir ce phénomène de sortie de
confinement de cette semi liberté
finalement que nous avons et qui va nous
faire consommer quand juste quand vous
dites c'est un certain nombre de choses
qui valent ce fait vous vous dites qu'il
ya certains de vos confrères et à des
restaurants qui vont devoir fermer ou
vous dit que même vous vous allez devoir
vous réinventer des choses que vous
faisiez aujourd'hui vous ne pourrez pas
l'air largement inclus là dedans il ya
effectivement des choses qu'on doit
réinventer
voyez la vente en ligne par exemple nous
n'étions pas du tout prêt moi ce qui m'a
choqué après le premier confinement
c'est de voir que notre gastronomie
était out et que des gens qui ne
représentaient pas la gastronomie
française qui sont des industriels du
burger des industriels du nuggets sous
de l'industriel de la pizza industrie de
la pizza était lésée binda les plus
positifs et que nous gastronomie
française nous étions effondré donc il
faut qu'on se réinvente y compris dans
de la cuisine pas cher le la cuisine la
cuisine française bien souvent s'est
éloigné de sa cuisine rural
contrairement à l'italie par exemple
vous voyez vous pouvez manger de façon
qualitative en italie et pas cher donc
je pense qu'il faut rond et invente des
secteurs complet de la restauration de
qualité
je pense à des systèmes de cafétéria de
qualité avec des circuits courts avec
des idées vraiment pour réimplanter cela
est pas laisser la place aux géants qui
ont su finalement prendre toutes ses
parts de marché et aujourd'hui d'être
représentés
dans l'alimentation et dresse dans cette
cuisine à l'extérieur des foyers par un
marchand de burger ou un marchand de
pneus guette ça m'ennuie vraiment donc
je pense que nous mêmes dans cette
profession dans cette profession nous
sommes capables de réinventer du
l'agréable à manger et l'agréable à
payer on a entendu la colère de beaucoup
en de restaurateurs depuis le début de
cette crise est ce que vous avez eu le
sentiment de ne pas avoir été compris
par le gouvernement d'avoir été quelque
part un peu des boucs émissaires
non je jouais pas j'ai pas cette
impression
je pense que le gouvernement a fait en
sorte de nous entendre nous écoutent et
de regarder nos nos grandes difficultés
et puis aussi prendre un petit peu de
recul de dire oui vous êtes les
restaurateurs le monde de tourisme est
en grande difficulté le monde de
l'événementiel est complètement
aujourd'hui à quasiment complètement
disparu le monde de la culture
tous les métiers collatéraux à la
gastronomie sont en grande difficulté on
a parlé de l'agriculture eh bien voyez
tous les gens qui avaient fait de la
volaille pour les fêtes de fin d'année
ça a quand même été une tradition qui
est toujours ni soeur la marée c'est
héréditaire
donc je pense qu' un moment donné il
faut pas non plus être dans l'émotion et
se dire et on attend aussi d'un
gouvernement qu'il prenne un peu de
recul et zyban on va y arriver vous
inquiétez pas on est là pour trouver les
solutions avec vous pas contre vous et
je pense qu'il ya eu une écoute du
gouvernement qu'est un dernier mot
là-dessus justement avant de parler de
formation c'est que c'est un sujet qui
vous tient beaucoup à coeur sur les
solutions à venir emmanuel macron hier
il a parlé de la mise en place d'un pass
sanitaires et vais en discuter avec le
gouvernement
cédric au le secrétaire d'état au
numérique était à votre place la semaine
dernière ils nous disaient travailler à
une sorte de qr code pour pouvoir aller
au restaurant est ce que ça vous semble
la bonne solution
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à mettre tout
ça en place ah oui complètement je pense
que c'est les restaurateurs le monde de
l'hôtellerie restauration n'a pas freiné
sur aucune des règles sanitaires qui
nous a été demandé au contraire on est
même allé au-delà donc aujourd'hui un
qrcode pourquoi pas si ça fait
progresser notre économie on va parler
des guyanes ormation plus d'informations
vous êtes à la tête d' école de
formation
l'artisanat peut être inclusif c'est ce
que vous puissiez démontré qu'elle
profite le stagiaire vous accueillez et
comment vous leur donnez cette deuxième
chance alors d'abord le profil de nos
stagiaires sont des gens en reconversion
des gens éloignés de l'emploi très
éloignées d'emploi en précarité pour
certains centres des gens qui sont sous
main de justice tous âges tous âges
parce qu'on n'aime pas les silos donc on
aime bien et ensuite eh bien oui on le
constate ces 92 % de retour à l'emploi
dans nos écoles parce qu'on parle de
projet quand on rentre dans nos écoles
vous avez 11 semaines de formation pour
porter votre projet et ça fonctionne
plutôt bien et je crois et je suis apte
intimement convaincu j'en parlais avec
olivier klein ya pas très longtemps et
on se disait on regardait comme ça sur
une dizaine d'années ce qui avaient été
les plus grands moteurs d'inclusion et
bien c'était l'art l'artisanat et le
sport donc dans ces trois secteurs nous
sommes proactifs pour aider des
personnes qui sont éloignés de l'emploi
très éloignées de l'emploi ou en
précarité pour les remettre dans une
idée métier dans une idée
d'épanouissement que te dire dans ce
pays reine des choses formidables à
faire on peut entreprendre
on peut entreprendre pour sa vie on peut
s'épanouir tout n'est pas borné personne
est assignée à l'échec personnes étaient
assignés à un quartier c'est vrai que
certains expliquent la montée des
violences qu'on constate actuellement
par un certain désoeuvrement par un
manque de perspective un manque de
confiance en l'avenir est ce que c'est
un une analyse que vous partagez sa mémé
mais bien sûr mais il faut arrêter de le
partager de de faire des constats en se
disant on va faire peut-être que non non
oui il faut y aller on le fait nous ça
fait quand même trente ans nous
constatons ensemble de phénomènes et
chaque fois ça fait aussi trente ans que
nous constatons que dès lors qu'il ya un
projet il ya une reprise de perspectives
et et ça fonctionne très très très bien
donc je dis pas que tout est facile je
dis pas que c'est simple je n'y passe
dans certains quartiers ce n'est pas
extrêmement compliqué d'être un bon
élève ou un mauvais élève
dans les deux cas c'est compliqué bien
sûr que le régalien à une application
extrêmement forte a apporté dans ces
quartiers mais a apporté aussi en
ruralité c'est pour ça que nos écoles
qui sont dans des quartiers politique de
la ville aujourd'hui vont aussi en
milieu rural qui rentrent qu'ils
rencontrent aussi de grandes difficultés
l'actualité nous le nous le fait
constater donc je pense qu'il faut
travailler très tôt sur la petite
enfance sur l'aide à la parentalité
c'est bien beau de vouloir condamner les
parents il faut aussi travailler sur
l'aide à la parentalité et ça c'est tout
des choses que nous faisons avec nos
écoles pour redonner une perspective
vous savez quand vous n'avez pas de
projet pour garder le seul qui va vous
ensevelir or quand un projet vous
redresser la tête et la vie c'est entre
l'ordre et le désordre
mais quand vous avez un projet vous
regarder devant vous et là la réussite
de ces écoles que ce soit puisse in mode
d'emploi boulangerie mode d'emploi
passeport pour l'emploi média social
foot toutes ces écoles aujourd'hui
produisent des personnes qui reprennent
leur vie en main et dans 92% des cas
voire des fois dans le 100 % des cas
elle retrouve l'épanouissement métier et
on voit d'ailleurs sur notre antenne ces
images tournées dans votre école de
formation merci beaucoup merci merci
était notre invité ce matin pascal on
regarde la haine du républicain lorrain
sur la crise sanitaire ou est sous haute
surveillance est la moselle la meurthe
et moselle qui font partie des fameux 20
départements touchés d'ailleurs chocolat
moselle après les amants équipe c'est le
plus touché est la norme inquiétudes à
la fois des habitants et puis des
professionnels qui dans ces départements
dans le heureusement souffre un peu plus
qu'ailleurs et merci à thierry marx je
reparle de votre livre celui qui conte
qui ne combat pas a déjà perdu ses deux
éditions flammarion merci beaucoup merci
d'avoir essayé notre invité on passe ce
site au club des territoires la mutuelle
nationale territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux vous présente le club des
territoires angie acteurs engagés dans
la transition zéro carbone des régions
vous présente le club des territoires
[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous présente le
globe des territoires et vont rejoindre
dans quelques instants pour ce club
arnaud benedetti césar arman est content
calme et on parlera des annonces de jean
castex vingt départements placés sous
surveillance renforcée des concertations
vont avoir lieu avec les élus pour voir
les décisions à prendre cette méthode
qu'on vante l ces élus on sera avec le
maire de brest françois grosdidier on
lui posera la question est plus parlant
de la nouvelle stratégie de
communication du gouvernement qui misent
de plus en plus sur les réseaux sociaux
pour attirer notamment les jeunes on va
en parler on suivra l'actualité dans nos
régions sera clermont ferrand avec
charles vigier du journal la montagne
qui nous présentera son port série sur
l'agriculture et l'agriculture s'étaient
justement le thème de nos reportages en
région cette semaine on va faire du bien
[Musique]